hey guys if you're watching this video
there's a really good chance that you
know i am a high school mathematics
teacher and you may even have seen
enough of my videos to know that being a
high school mathematics teacher means i
have high school mathematics students
that i teach and i do all the regular
things with my students that every other
teacher does include give my students
assessment tasks and what you're about
to see is the results it's the
submission for an assessment task that i
gave to some of my students who study
something called year 12 mathematics
extension 2. it's a really high level of
sophisticated mathematics and one of the
cool things we get to do as an internal
school assessment is give students the
chance to explore different levels and
areas of mathematics that attach to the
things we explicitly teach in class but
aren't necessarily things that we have
directly shown them but sort of connect
and they can explore and understand
using the knowledge that we've helped
them develop so this is a particular
student of mine whose submission his
assignment i'm particularly proud of i
think you guys will enjoy it so have fun
and i don't want to say anything to
spoil the video because it's got a very
clever kind of twist in it but i hope
you guys like what you see and learn
something from it
from a bad hair day to a tragic natural
disaster wind can be extremely
disruptive
but what if wind didn't exist would
airplanes still fly can birds still fly
well what if i tell you that there is
always at least one place on earth where
there is no wind
[Music]
in this video we'll be going through the
concept of euless characteristic and the
poingee hops theorem and we'll be
combining all of that into another known
theorem to understand why there exists a
place without wind
firstly we must understand what a convex
polyhedron is a convex polyhedron is
simply a polyhedron for which a line
connecting any two points on the surface
always lies in the interior of the
polyhedron
this refers to a relationship known as
euler's characteristic euler's
characteristic tells us that for any
convex polyhedron the vertices minus
edges plus faces is always equal to two
let's have a look at an example
consider the following a tetrahedron has
four vertices six edges and four faces
a cube has eight vertices twelve edges
and six faces and an octahedron has six
vertices twelve edges and eight faces
now applying euler's characteristic by
subtracting the edges from the vertices
and summing the faces they're all equal
to 2.
similarly this would be the result for
any convex polyhedra but does this still
hold true for a sphere after all we are
trying to find a place on earth with no
wind and earth is a sphere
so let's consider a sphere passing
through the origin with radius 1 with
the x y y z and the x z planes showing
we can see that as the respective planes
cut across the sphere we actually have
six vertices twelve edges and eight
faces and so euler's characteristic for
a sphere also equals to two
but what does this have to do with wind
well before moving forward let's see if
we can prove that euler's characteristic
is true for all convex polyhedra as this
will help to complete our final proof
later on
in doing so we need to address some key
definitions
we can reframe the idea of the convicts
polyhedra in terms of planar graphs
now if we draw a set of dots and connect
them with lines between them this is
known as a graph
now if the lines don't intersect this is
known as a planar graph and a planar
graph is connected if there is a path
between every pair of vertex
so let's consider a path starting on any
vertex on a planar graph that later
returns to the same starting vertex
this is called a cycle and a planar
graph without any cycles is known as a
tree we must know that a tree has only
one face which is
the entire plane surrounding it so
euler's characteristic reduces to
vertices minus edges equals one which is
just edges equals vertices
minus one
now to finally prove all this
characteristic there are many ways to do
so but we'll consider the approach using
the number of edges
before we start off our proof let v be
the number of vertices e be the number
of edges and f with the number of faces
in a planar graph g
step one prove true for our base case
well our base case occurs when edges is
equal to zero
so when edges is equal to zero the graph
consists of a single vertex with a
single region surrounding it
so that means that our euler's
characteristic just becomes one minus
zero
plus one which is equal to two which is
our right hand side
so the formula holds true for our base
case
moving on to step two our inductive
hypothesis
we'll assume that the theorem is true
for all connected planar graphs with e
minus 1 edges
and moving on to step 3
we must consider true cases for our
connected planar graph
our first case is when our graph g does
not contain a cycle
so if g does not contain a cycle then g
must be a tree
and we know that trees only have one
face which is the entire plane
surrounding it
so referring back to our definitions we
actually now have
v minus one edges
so
our value for euler's characteristic
just becomes v minus brackets v minus
one plus one which reduces to
two
so the formula holds true for our first
case
now moving on to case two when g
contains at least one cycle c
so let's consider this cycle shown below
now
if we remove an edge from the cycle c
this means that it doesn't remain a
cycle anymore as the trail doesn't end
at the starting vertex
so this is simply a path p
now
our aim is to apply the inductive
hypothesis to this new graph
but our assumption was only true for
connected planar graphs
so if we remove an edge from our cycle c
then won't our graph become disconnected
well
not really because there still exists a
path between every pair of vertex
therefore our new graph has the same v
vertices and now has e minus one edges
but how about a number of faces
well initially our graph g had faces f1
and f2 but after removing the edge p
the faces f1 and f2 combined into one
face
so generally our new graph will have f
minus 1 faces
hence by the inductive hypothesis the
theorem must hold true for our new graph
g without the edge p
and by substituting our values and
simplifying we can actually see that it
does in fact equal to two
thus by the principle of mathematical
induction euler's characteristic for all
convex polyhedra is always equal to two
however we must note that this is only
one case of euler's characteristic where
it is equal to two other surfaces such
as a ring or a double torus will have
other euler characteristic values
so to simplify this idea if you take
something with an euler's characteristic
of let's say two and morph it into
something else through continuous
bending and stretching without tearing
then the euler characteristic will
remain
two
hence
surfaces with the same euler
characteristic are said to be
homeomorphic
two surfaces are homeomorphic if we can
get one surface from the other by
stretching and bending the surface as if
it was made from a piece of clay now
that we understand the basic principle
behind the euler characteristic
let's consider this ring which is better
known as a taurus
this has an euler characteristic of zero
instead of trying to compute the euler
characteristic for a taurus we can
actually use a planar model to study the
surface more easily
consider the construction of a torus as
shown here
considering this rectangle the rectangle
has four vertices but in the planar
model of the torus every vertex is
actually the same vertex labeled v
hence there is only one vertex on a
torus
the rectangle has four edges as well but
in the planar model edges e1 and e1
stick together to become the same edge
on the torus and the same applies for
the edge e2
and the total number of faces remain one
hence the euler characteristic for our
taurus is one minus two plus one which
is zero
this may seem like a lot but bear with
me all of this will contribute to our
final proof later on
now moving on from euler's
characteristic let's consider a world
based on a torus with a constant wind
blowing around the world
this constant wind can be represented by
a vector field
a vector field is used to model the
speed and direction of a moving fluid
represented as a collection of
individual vectors
now if we begin to slowly close the hole
we are eventually left with a zero
vector meaning that there's no wind
viewing this from an alternate
perspective we are actually just
observing a sphere and there are in fact
two zero vectors now this means that the
sphere has two points where there is no
wind and the taurus had zero points
linking this back to our previous
concept the sphere had an euler
characteristic of two whilst a taurus
had an euler characteristic of zero
so what's going on
well this has to do with french
mathematician henry poincare and german
mathematician haynes hox whose
contributions led to the hip-hop theorem
the pointy-hop theorem states that for a
continuous vector field on the surface
the sum of the indices at every point
where the vector field is zero is equal
to the euler characteristic of that
surface
to understand what this means we need to
consider the different ways in which a
vector field can be zero
here are some examples where we have a
zero vector present
now each of these vector fields has an
index otherwise known as a winding
number so let's take a look at our first
example
we'll place a hypothetical vector on the
surface of the field and oriented to
face in the direction of a vector in
that region
we'll then move this hypothetical vector
anti-clockwise along the surface whilst
maintaining its direction in terms of a
vector in that region
in this scenario the vector results in
one anti-clockwise rotation and hence
this vector field with a zero vector has
an index of plus one
similarly let's consider this example
just like before we're going to place an
imaginary vector on the surface pointing
it in the direction of a vector at that
point as it moves along the surface it
also makes an anti-clockwise rotation
and hence it has an index of plus one
but how about this vector field
following the same process as before
instead of the imaginary vector making
an anti-clockwise rotation it actually
ends up making a clockwise rotation
thus this vector field with a zero
vector has an index of minus one
now let's go back to our sphere
from earlier on we know that the sphere
has two zero vectors one at the top and
one at the bottom if we zoom onto those
two zero vectors we can see that both
vector fields have an index of plus one
and we also know that a sphere has an
euler characteristic of two
thus the poinky hops theorem holds true
as the sum of the indices at every point
where the vector field is 0 which in our
case is plus 2 is equal to the euler
characteristic of that surface which
again is plus two
therefore coming back to our world built
on a torus we actually have a vector
field that is non-zero everywhere as the
euler characteristic for a torus is zero
hence as we know that the poincare hop
theorem always holds true we can
conclude that for any sphere with a
continuous tangent vector field there
must always be at least one zero vector
such as example shown here which has an
index of plus two
and this actually ties into our main
theorem as to why there is a place on
earth with no wind which is officially
known as the hairy ball theorem why is
it called that you ask well simple
explanation
essentially the theorem proposes that
you can't comb a ball of hair without
having some hair sticking up
and since wind on earth is like a
projection of hair on a ball
this theorem implies that there is
always a place with no wind
whilst the actual proof of this theorem
is way beyond the scope of this course
we can actually simplify this proof
using a method from our natural proof
topic which beautifully integrates the
concepts of both euler's characteristic
and the poinker hop theorem
just like starting any other proof we'll
first find our implication
if there exists a sphere with a
continuous tangent vector field then
there must be at least one zero vector
moving on we'll assume that there is a
continuous tangent vector field on a
sphere which is non-zero everywhere
therefore according to our assumption
the euler characteristic of a sphere
must be equal to zero
however remembering back to what the
poinque hog theorem said the sum of the
indices at every point where the vector
field is zero is equal to the euler
characteristic of that surface
so by considering the sum of the indices
it actually adds up to plus two and
hence our euler characteristic should be
two as well
and this leads to a contradiction as the
two values of the euler characteristic
do not match
thus a non-zero vector field cannot
exist it must be zeroed somewhere
and there we have it there must always
be at least one place on earth where
there is no wind
but hold up we are focused on one
application of the harry potter theorem
so far but it doesn't really end here
there are actually many more real world
situations that act like hairy balls
in early 2007 scientists from an
engineering team employed the hairy ball
theorem to nanotechnology
nanotechnology is a field of research
concerned about building things on the
scale of atoms and molecules
what they did is that they covered gold
nanoparticles with monolayers which
essentially made it into tiny furballs
as a result of the theorem the
scientists knew that at any given point
there would always be some hair standing
from the surface
even if there would be only one
this always allowed for the
nanoparticles to attach themselves to
each other in any circumstance
this was a breakthrough for scientists
as it was mentioned that it may open a
new avenue for using nanoparticles due
to its new functionality and the best
part is is that the theorem is not only
limited to what it is it extends way
beyond the idea of wind on earth and
nanotechnology and really makes us
appreciate the beautiful nature of
mathematics in our world